[Applause]  shot five of  seven but not a huge factor  but just just didn't seem as impactful  nice effort by bull he's up there he's  tippy toeing  dozier going to try it again  keep it going and bowl puts it in that's  the kind of effort michael malone will  appreciate scott  that's extra effort uh that was not  there earlier in the third and the  fourth well he went a long way to get a  double double from the rebound  department just on this one right here  may hurt the shooting percentage  but kept it alive kept it alive and  finally gets that last one to go  in and the foul bowl has 10 rebounds now  you just had eight no i'm kidding he  just had eight right there  so bowl bowl in his debut 12  minutes five points